[Music]
if you ask me new BTS music means it's
gonna be a good weekend that's a brand
new day a new tune by j-hope MV
alongside Zara Larsson and fans are
calling it the Bop of the century
I do think you know if you have if you
have something you want to say as an
artist I think that that's the most
important thing if you have something to
say and you have the voice to say it you
should use it 100% and then I've never
been in a situation where everyone's
been like no you know it's a collab it's
a collab in the studio with a song with
just everything around it this is
actually the second of three songs that
will be featured in BTS as upcoming
video game
BTS world
[Applause]
drew hey third track is slated for
release on June 21st while the entire
video game soundtrack will be out on
June 28th the game comes out on June
25th and all I'm saying is I hope song
number three is a collab with Billy
Eilish especially after this magic that
jungkook made and if that wasn't proof
enough the guys have said they want a
billy club who is like the dream for BTS
to collaborate with that would just kind
of like blow your mind right this news
are Larsen duet also it does seem to
mark a fun trend for the guys teaming up
with fabulous female pop stars most
recently they released a boy with love
with Halsey
[Music]
alright guys what do you think of this
new song who else do you want to see the
guys collaborate with let me know and
for all the latest on BTS keep it locked
to all things et until next time I'm
Katie Krauss and bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]